Yeah, I mean, it sounds like you might run a marathon before I do. You want to run a marathon? No, it's too long. Connor, that's not, that doesn't make me feel good. It doesn't make me feel good to hear that you think it's too long. welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 112 recorded on January 4th 2022 my name is Connor and today with my co-host Bryce we conclude our 2022 retrospective and talk about Bryce's 2023 running goals all right is that so that's the 2022 summary. No personal stuff? No personal 2022 highlights?
I mean, there's lots of work-related things that I'm proud of. I'm proud of a ton of the work that the C++ Core Library team at NVIDIA has done in the last year. We recently released our, our implementation of super-spoilers senders and, and that's now on GitHub. I think that's been pretty cool. It's a big accomplishment and we made a ton of progress on the, the proposal for senders in the committee. There's all this, you know, this quantum C++ stuff that I've been very, had a very limited amount of work on,
but it's still pretty cool. Glad to be involved in that. I'm pretty proud of everything that the C++ Library Evolution Group has gotten done the past year, starting the transition from completely remote to hybrid. Proud of the shape and scope of C++23. So yeah, I think those are my 2022 highlights. And I got to go to some great conferences. That's another 2022 highlight for me,
the return of the C++ face-to-face conferences. That's been fun. Yep. Well, that's my perfect segue. So Bryce, very unstructured. Even though I gave him advance warning, I say come up with your top things. Connor has a list. No, I have a list here. I wrote a list. Whoa, look at that. Did you miss anything on your list? Then another line that says return of C++ face-to-face conferences. And then 2023 says Empire Strikes Back and lists some details.
And then says there's also a line item for Rust because I think Rust is going to continue gaining popularity this next year. Yeah, yeah. I was very excited. So yesterday or a couple days ago, Tom Palmer, I'm really hoping I got that name right. He's the context-free YouTube individual or has a YouTube by the name of context-free that posts a lot of programming language stuff. He has a website called Languish, which is programming language rankings based on GitHub statistics. And Rust has been trending very much upwards over the last few years. And C++ has kind of been static.
And then C has also kind of been up and down. And Go has also been on the rise. So I usually look at those four languages. And it looked, based on the trend, that Rust was number 11, and it was going to hop into the top 10 and kick down C. But actually what happened was C++ went down, but the ranking stayed the same, and they're just above Go at the moment. So next quarter, because they update the stats every three months,
Go might overtake C++. And Rust actually went down to 12, and I think C went down to 11 because Markdown somehow popped up into the top 10, which in my opinion isn't really a programming language, but it's in the statistics. Well, didn't we have a whole discussion once about is HTML a programming language? I felt bad about that. I take that back. HTML is a programming language, I think, now.
If HTML is a programming language, why isn't Markdown a programming language, I think, now. If HTML is a programming language, why isn't Markdown a programming language? Can't HTML do a lot more than Markdown? Markdown is like a completely watered-down version of what is possible with HTML. You know, I feel like every time in the history of computing that somebody has said, like, this thing has got limited capabilities or it's a
watered-down version like two or three years later they're they're eating crow because somebody's written a you know a brain fuck interpreter in whatever that thing was yeah it is i was upset the other day i was listening to uh was it no No, it was Python Bytes, which is a Python podcast. And they were reviewing, I mean, the survey came out months ago, I thought, the 2022 Stack Overflow Survey. And they were getting upset because of the way the top programming languages question was done because it asks you to list all the technologies you've worked with and not your primary one.
And then because of that, SQL was like at the top of the list. And they were like, well, SQL is not a language. Like, you know, we shouldn't count that because people don't do it primarily. And I was like, that's so like SQL is definitely like. There's definitely, that's definitely a job. That's definitely a job description. And I think they were just upset because they lean, their bias is so hard towards Python. Like even, what was it, like when it was technologies that get used, they were upset that.NET was above Pandas and NumPy.
And they were like, well, that's not a fair comparison because.NET is a whole – and I was just like, Jesus, anytime a Python thing gets knocked down because some other technology, they're coming up with excuses for why it shouldn't be included in the survey or why it's not fair that the survey was conducted. And I was just like – anyways, it's just – we're all biased, but it just seems very – not disingenuous, but it's very weird when you're listening to a Python podcast and they're kind of getting upset that like, oh, well, you know, SQL. Do people even really use that as a full-time thing? They just use it on the side, maybe know, maybe a couple lines a year. It shouldn't be, shouldn't count. And I'm like, I mean, there's, SQL is very, very important. And to call it one of the most popular languages in the world, I don't think is an inaccurate statement.
Anyways. All right. 2022. My number three, you didn't list it. Very hurt, Bryce. Very hurt. Was our trip to San Diego, PLDI. Oh, that was great.
It was great. You know, I turned it into a little bit of a kind of vacation on the ends of the weekend surrounding it. But yeah, PLDI was awesome. Number two is switching to research. That's like been a dream job. And number one, it was the same as my number one for anyone that has been listening for over a year and they remember has been running but you know what we said at the end of our episode last year when we did this was we we had a bet or like a contest do you remember what that was yeah oh shit i'm gonna have lost this because it was we were comparing i think i you asked how far i'd run and then i
don't know it was 3 000 or or 4,000 and then you were checking to see if you had biked more than I ran and then you said that's not even really a fair contest and so you said for 2022 your goal was to bike at least twice as much as I had run during the year and potentially you did because I remember when we were I can't remember if it was in San Diego or in CPP North. At some point we were in the same city and you were like, I got to go. I got to go. I got to go hop on the,
um, the, what do you call it? Not an electric bike. What do you like? Biking? Well, I,
I, I rode biking. I've definitely not, um, not done more than you, but I do keep track of all of my... I mean, that counts, whether you're out on the road. That would be like saying I don't get to count running on a treadmill. I'm in Strava right now, and I can't figure out how to access last year's.
We'll cut all this out all right how much how much what's your total distance my total this it doesn't give a breakdown for an inside outside of running but in 2022 my total distance is My total distance. It doesn't give a breakdown for an inside outside of running, but in 2022, my total distance is 4,482 kilometers. 4,482. So you're going to have to be basically very close to 9,000, 8,000. I do not think I am. Cause I,
I haven't been doing, uh, uh, the bike the entire time inside. I've been doing a good bit, um, uh, on the, like the cross trainer. Um, so I've got 3,888 on the cross trainer, um, and 489 inside. So, so 4,000, like 4,400 in total. So it didn't even beat me at 1.0.
Yeah. Yeah. But I think that that's, that's because I've been, I haven't, I just haven't been biking as much. A lot of it's been on the cross trainer. Oh yeah.
Where you cover a lot more. This app here tells me how many calories I burned. Does, do you have a way to get that information? Uh, it says activities, 316, distance, which we already covered,
time, 377 hours. It does not look like it tells me calories. Although my Garmin app might. Because I know Garmin tracks my calories. Also, I have from my little tracker here, I have climbed 437 kilometers. 4,000 kilometers? 437 kilometers.
4,000 kilometers? 437. What is that, hiking or biking? That's height gain from the gym, from stair machines, stuff like that. Damn, you got me beat there. I mean, my... Well... Actually, no, never mind. My elevation gain is... 21,000 meters? What is that?
21 kilometers? Yeah. You said you had 4,000, no? No, no, no. I have 437 kilometers. Of elevation gain? Yeah. Isn't that going to like the moon or something, man?
Yeah, maybe. I don't know. Wait, how far? For calories, I have 100. Oh, shit. Never mind. I was off by like three orders of magnitude. Yeah.
Or two orders of magnitude. The moon is further away. It's 384,000 kilometers away. So whoops. The moon is further away than. I apologize to the astronomers that are listening that just died laughing. I have 170,000 calories burned. And I still lost, like, no weight this year.
Yeah, I have no idea. I mean, it tells me... What's your average pace for minutes per kilometer? Doesn't look like it tells me that either. Anyways, I have exciting news for you. What is your news that you're gonna be exciting news is that uh i may start running whoa look at that because i was uh perfect in the city and uh we were trying to get to our favorite restaurant before it uh closed and so i was running a little bit and i was like you know what this is not miserable this isn't like the worst thing i've ever done um
and so and and also um you're right next you're right next to central park too man it's like running one of the best places i'm actually that's the one downside of where i live is that uh well in manhattan i'm actually oh yeah that's that's that's right that's right i was thinking that you were next to um the sushi restaurant which you're not yeah um and i'm pretty far away from uh uh oh the sushi restaurant we went to that's the one on the west side i'm talking about the one of it on the east side the sugarfish on the east side yeah yeah um which is it's also further away from Central Park. We're in a really nice location, but for like the upper part of Manhattan, we're actually
in a place that's pretty far away from Central Park. However, the girlfriend also used to run and she's feeling like she's getting out of shape. Absolutely not true, but she still feels like she's getting out of shape. And she hasn't been able to exercise as much the past few months. absolutely not true, but she still feels like she's getting out of shape. And, um, uh, and she hasn't been able to exercise as much the past few months. And so I keep telling her, you gotta, you should come exercise with me every day. And she's like, yeah, I should, we should do that. And, uh, and so now I'm thinking, well, maybe, maybe we could do running together because that's something that she used to do. There's this perfect, perfect man. And you know what? And
then it makes it easier from traveling and I don't have access to a gym. Yep. It's, I mean, I'm starting a running podcast this month. You're starting a running podcast. With one of my best friends from university, Yubai, and he was a varsity track athlete. He used to run 800 meters, so was very, very fast back in university, but he hasn't been running for a while either. And, uh, I told him that we're going to start a podcast and then I'm going to force him to join my run club. And, uh, it's going to follow the journey, our journey, because he's going to be getting
back into running, but he's also like way more knowledgeable about training and stuff. Cause he did it for, for years when he was in university. Um, yeah. Anyways, this is great this is great yeah and there's a couple people in the c++ community i think barry uh who we mentioned earlier um or might maybe that might have been before we hit the record button um i think he he's more of a swimmer but i think he runs now and teamer also released that c++ lightning talk about best places to run at c++ conferences so maybe we'll get to run together so how do i get started how do i start running just honestly my recommendation to people is do the as much as you want to like most people but i want to do like 30 seconds to two minutes and then i'm like no i would I would like to walk now. Do that. Do that. Literally. Like there are a lot of running programs for like what they call like couch to 5k, which
is like, I don't run and I want to run a 5k race. A lot of the recommendations there are like run for a minute, walk for a minute, run for a minute and do that. Even if you only go out and do that for 10 minutes, like that's where you start. And like at first, depending on your fitness level, that might seem extremely easy, but like a lot of like, I think the number one problem for people with like starting to run is actually just the starting part. Because if you tell someone, Hey, you have to go out and run nonstop for 60 minutes, like that just for a lot of people, it sounds boring and it's, it's very hard to get
motivated to go and do that. But like, if you just tell yourself, you know, I think there's a couple different, like Jason and I talked about this at one point, Jason Turner about like, as soon as you get out the door, like that's the hardest part. And then it's like, even if you tell yourself, you know, you know, I want to read a book or something, but your goal is like, I'm going to read like a page a day. It's like, well, once you've read, once you've read one page, it's like, well, I mean, I can read a little bit more than that. So like once you get out the door and have your shoes on, you know, it's usually easy to run, you know, whether it's one kilometer or five minutes, 10 minutes, whatever you want. And, uh, then you just start increasing that ratio. So if you go
from running a minute, uh, walking a minute to like running for two minutes and walking for a minute until you get to the point where you can just run nonstop. And I mean, I personally, like I got a little bit stomach ill over the holidays and like didn't want to go out and run. Yeah. And so I went and just used the treadmill because I didn't really have the energy to leave. And like I, on an average per day, run like an hour and a half. And I like I love it. I'm addicted to it. It's like one of the most important things in my life. Running on the treadmill was like, it was like, I was dying inside. I just like, whatever it is, like not, not having the moving like there was a health podcast that mentioned something called optic flow, which is I don't
know if it's complete made up, you know, garbage, but there's been some studies done that show that like one of the best things for thinking and like getting yourself, um, your brain activated and stuff is like optic flow, which is whether you're being in a car and you're seeing things go by you or you're biking or you're running, like having like the physical world move past you is like the brain likes it. And for whatever reason, like I had the hardest time even getting to 60 minutes on a treadmill. Whereas when I'm outside and I've got my podcast or music or whatever, I can run,
you know, hour and a half, two hours. And even if it's like, if it's raining, it's snowing, like I always prefer being outside. And so that would be my other recommendation is I think whether you want to
listen to the optic flow studies is that at least for me, I find treadmill running just like so boring. And it's also just like the time seems to go by so much slower. Whereas like I'll hit the 5k mark, um, of, uh, however long I'm going to run. And it's just like, it just disappears when you're outside by the, you know, the waterfront in Toronto is a very beautiful place to run. And, uh, it just like, it just disappears. Whereas you're in one spot just going blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah on a, on a treadmill. Um, yeah, it's, I mean,
I, I sort of feel the same way too. It's like, it's easier for me if I can actually get out and bike, but, um, you know, I've been traveling so much and, uh, in the winter it's, you know, uh, you know, harder. Um, but, uh, I, I, I sort of like just going to the gym and just like being able to, you know, watch my show while I'm, you know, on the bike. And like when I was biking out, like in the city, I'll be listening to a podcast, but I don't mind, I don't mind just like being in the gym. I do feel like I get maybe more of a workout when I'm out like biking, um, like on an actual road. Um, and I, you know, usually feel a little bit better about that. Um, but, uh, I'm, I'm perfectly happy to, to, to do stuff inside
too. I forgot the other part of the, of the, uh, uh, the, the thing with the girlfriend, which is that, I don't know how we got on the topic, but, uh, uh, I think one of the two of us threatened to the other one, uh, that, that they couldn't run a marathon or that they shouldn't run a marathon or something like that. And, uh, long story short, uh, I think we came, uh, I, I told her we're gonna, we're gonna, we're gonna train to run and then we're going to go run the Sydney Marathon. I don't even know if there's a Sydney Marathon. I just like picked one of the travel destinations that we would like to go to. I assume that there is.
So that's our goal. We're going to run the Sydney Marathon. Sydney Marathon. It's a thing. I am going to. So you know that the London Marathon is right before, is right around when ACCU is this year. And I know this because my aunt is going to run the London Marathon.
Oh, wow. And she's going to be there at the same time that I am for ACCU. I mean, London's one of the majors, so it's very hard to get in. I'm sure Sydney's much easier. It's like, yeah, that's impressive. Your aunt must be. Yeah, she's a pretty good runner. Must be a pretty good runner.
Yeah, she claims this will be the last marathon she'll do. How many has she done? I guess she's done a lot. She's run like pretty much every day of her life. I think for the past 30 or 40 years or something. Wow, that's impressive yeah yeah i mean uh it sounds like you might run a marathon before i do um you don't run a marathon nope that's too long i uh connor that's not that doesn't make me feel good it doesn't make me feel
good to hear that you think it's too long no it, it's just because I have this thing where I like when I hit the two-hour mark. And I love – It takes more than two hours? Yeah. Well, the marathon, depending on – I mean the world record is like two hours and one minute. So unless if you're faster than Elliot Ketrogi, which I can confidently tell you that you're not, you're going to be running more than two hours. I might not be, but the girlfriend, she's really fast. Like she's short, but she's fast.
I mean, I think the women's record is 2.14. So she's still probably not running. All right, I'll tell her that's the number. But yeah, I just have this thing where like, so here's my one minute take on marathons. I plan to run marathons and upgrade, but my goal is to just get faster so that I if I get faster at the shorter things, I'll hopefully be getting faster at the longer things. But also for half marathons, you don't really need to fuel like with a.k.a. You don't need to like eat gels and like consume calories, Whereas in a marathon, you have to like basically
fuel. And I love running because it's so simple. You just put shoes on, maybe a coat if it's cold out in the winter, and then you just go run. You just go in a circle, go in a straight line and come back. You know, it's pretty straightforward. Whereas when you start running marathons, like you have to be concerned about one, like how are you going to fuel? What are you going to fuel with? Are you going to use gels? Are you going to use little syrupy things you need to carry like four to six of them with you so like you're running with shorts that need to have some form of pockets or some form of things to hold these anyways like as soon as you start getting into like you know you're running so long that there's like logistics involved and
that you need to basically have the equivalent of a freaking sandwich uh you know it's i start to ask myself is you know like uh like what are we doing here um yeah uh and also too yeah just like running for three or four hours does not sound like it's i'm very impressed by like everyone in my run club they're all you know there's a huge group of them that are signing up to go and do berlin this year which is one of the other major there's six major marathons um for listeners that don't know that it's Chicago, New York, London, Berlin, Tokyo, and Boston. Yeah, it's very impressive. Let's listen to me again. Chicago, Chicago, New York are the two US ones. Or no, sorry, Chicago, New York, Boston.
Boston is, I think, considered like the, and this will upset the other cities, but it's considered like the premier one, especially for Americans. And then London, Berlin, and Tokyo. That's untrue. The New York one is, of course, the premier one because it's in New York the best I mean uh yeah I'm sure there's a a ton of runners that will fight with each other about which one is uh has sort of more esteem I mean Boston the reason I think most people are in agreement that Boston is is because like they shut down the whole city for a day and like even people that don't care about running go out and like it's turned the whole city turns into a party and I think there's typically a baseball game or something that happens that's timed to end with like what when like the biggest crowds are entering somewhere new york though i've heard that it's
just like new york is amazing because other than a couple of the bridges you just have like people cheering the whole time like it's people yeah although super freaking annoying. I got, last year, I was taking stuff to my storage unit, which is on 1st and 62nd. Between 1st and York on 62nd. And I get in the Uber with the three crates for the storage unit. Guy drives me up. And, uh, and then like, I really, we both realized we get there that like, shit, the marathon's happening. Um, and the marathon comes either down set,
maybe it's down second, um, uh, like North of the Queensborough bridge. And so like, there's no way for me to get over to um uh to first in 62nd and and i i still i you know i was frustrated and occasionally make bad decisions when frustrated and so the guy's like i can just drop you here and instead of being like no take me back to my apartment i's like, I can just drop you here. And instead of being like, no, take me back to my apartment. I'm like, all right, fine. Just drop me here. And so then I get out and now I have like three crates of things. And like, I'm so frustrated that I sent the guy away that I don't even do the smart thing of like getting another Uber. I'm like, I'll just walk back. And so I walked back to my apartment and i had like i had like a little hand cart um and i took that hand cart from 60 second all the way back down to um uh to 51st and second
um which is where we live and um yeah i was very unhappy like there's no it's just like okay like just for this day like you just can't cross over to this part of the city. Come on. If there's a parade, fine, because there'll be breaks in the parade and they'll let you through. But the marathon, they don't let you through. This is... I mean, there's 50,000 people that run it, so... There are some disruptions in New York that, like, I made peace with. Like, during the UN General Assembly, I had an Instacart delivery get canceled. And the guy sends me a message and he's like, I'm sorry, dude.
Like, you know, Biden just flew in and like the bridges are like closed. Like I can't deliver your groceries because like Biden's motorcade is like closed everything off. And it's like, okay, like that's, you know what? That's fine. The president's coming into town. You know, I, I, I made my peace with that. But, but the marathon shutting down, shutting, shutting down so much in New York for the day, I don't like that.
I mean, says the guy who's signed up to basically run a marathon in the future now, you're going to be – Yeah, but not in my city, in somebody else's city. The disruption can be somewhere else. I mean, I predict that if you run the Sydney Marathon, you're probably going to end up running the New York Marathon. Yeah, let's –'s i i as i told the girlfriend we can like maybe start with like a 5k or like a 1k yeah they got 1ks they got
the the new york um the new york uh fifth avenue mile that's a exciting race to to run right by uh central park mostly downhill you pick up some speed, some serious speed. This is exciting. This is exciting. I guess I'll have to get running shoes. I'm sure the girlfriend has running shoes. She has a lot of shoes. Yeah.
So some of them must be running shoes. That's my other tip is, I mean, depending. So hard for me to buy shoes. This is what I'll say is that like running shoes, especially running shoes these days, cause they're made so well, they have like a lifetime. Um, and some people, they say they can run on their shoes even until they get holes in them, like 2000 kilometers. Uh, I do not have that genetic gifts. And like, once I hit like the 600, depending on the type of shoe kilometer mark on a shoe,
even if it looks perfectly fine, like all of the cushion and stuff is like shot especially like i'll start to feel like pain right underneath my knees like at the top of my shins as soon as that starts happening i just knew i know i need a new pair of shoes um so like if you have i mean it could potentially be like form or something like that but um if you are running on like a pair of old trainers that are not specifically designed for whatever, yeah, you might want to just buy. And I would just go to like your local running shoes. Like people at running shoe stores, they typically know what they're doing. Yeah. And they'll hook you up.
Cool. All right. Well, wait. Do we have any other 2023 Slovenia goals for 2023? We're going to be in that general region this summer for the C++ committee meeting. So maybe. What do you mean maybe? We're definitely going.
We've committed to the fans. I'm going to Slovenia. I guarantee the listeners that I will be in Slovenia at some point in 2023. Will Bryce be there? We don't know. Connor, you're making a threat to somebody who you know loves travel and too has not only great capabilities to figure out how to get to someplace like Slovenia, but also has like all the miles and the points and the things. So like this is...
If I tell you when I'm going to be in Slovenia, can I just assume that you will show up? I mean, yeah. All right. The people of Slovenia, the people of Ljubljana, we're coming. I'm excited. It's quite a beautiful. We've seen photos when I was preparing for that show a year ago.
It's pretty beautiful. I've also heard, speaking of running, that apparently Slovenia, I heard this on one of my running podcasts, has like a huge running community and they've got a bunch of really awesome races that like fly under the radar because i guess i don't know slovenia is not as well known as some other european countries yeah um anyways people get it confused with uh other countries yeah it is and i would i don't know why i thought but i thought slovakia would be close like bordering slovenia like as i just like figured while they were naming the country. Yeah, I think a lot of Americans would assume that, yeah. But it's not the case at all.
And it's not. Slovakia borders Poland, but then it's a couple countries over. Yeah. Anyways, Empire Strikes Back. But I feel like everybody knows where Poland is because, you know, it's a big country. Yeah, it's very big. And is that just why people know? I guess it's next to ukraine right so i mean i'm sure most people were curious about the conflict and lifted a map and etc um uh well i
would hope that i would hope that people know where poland is for reasons other than it's near ukraine uh i mean i've i've been there multiple times now I'll probably be in Poland next year a couple times probably at least once for visiting my girlfriend's family but also I'm hoping to get to Code Dive next year yeah yeah it's a great conference
I got oh yeah and I got my talk accepted to Lambda Days so Composition Intuition it's happening in krakow which is also in poland for listeners when is that that's in june and i'm thinking of maybe maybe turning that into like a bit of a travel vacation and then go and visiting some stuff which potentially i mean yeah it depends on if you can get to slovenia but if i
get accepted to c++ on c then that's at the end of june if you get accepted yes it's true i mean i've never submitted to uh the last before this talk composition intuition i think my last talk got rejected oh that's not true two talks ago. I submitted to speak at Strange Loop in 2022. Yeah, that looks like a cool conference. Yeah, I think it's actually it's over now. They've ended it
and the last thing I heard that 2023 was going to be the last edition of the conference but then if you click on the register oh no, it is back up.
Yeah, yeah. So I might go register for this right now because i've never been i would i would die to speak there but uh i mean i wouldn't die that's a figure of speech um it's actually paradoxical you can't speak if you're dead anyways um that is true yeah you can go register i'm not sure if they even have a call for papers or they're just going to do like the best of years past and and bring back speakers that have already spoken there because if i was running a conference that i had run for i don't know roughly a decade or more i would probably do something like that um but it does look like they are going to have a cfp that opens on april 3 So anyways, lots of stuff to look forward to. Yep.
Slovenia, Empire Strikes Back. Any other predictions or things that need to be said going into the year 2023? None come to mind. None come to mind. All right. I guess I hope everybody has a, has a great year.
Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day and a great year. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.